c'est non
les chroniques de la haine ordinaire
[Musique]
dimanche de la mi juin
de l'été c'est le plus beau jour le vrai
premier jour après 500 km alexandre
descendre l'automobile pour forcer le
portail de bois vers son
âne garé la voiture sous l'abri de
chaume à l'arrière l'ivresse désordonnée
des joie folle fait trépigner les deux
petites filles s'énerver
dans l'allée de sable hérissé des herbes
incongrue du printemps un lapin
stupéfait ses clips ce cul en l'air il a
l'air con et la poste huppé fait
aussi peu concernés qu un croque-mort à
la noce le chat sombre du voisin fou
s'en va à peine
au bout de l'allée à la maison sobrement
tarabiscoté balnéaire 1910 toile ardoise
murs blancs et briques cerné de vignes
sauvages quand il ouvre la porte la
chaleur enfermer ses montées du parquet
ni nourri des huiles de pain là senteurs
exotiques dépend des vieux navires
de l'autre côté des volets la terrasse
aux pierres bleues en contrebas immense
comme une éternité tranquille
frémissante à l'infini inéluctable comme
la mort et plus crédible que dieu la mer
considérable s'en fout intensément
la mer la vraie mère l'atlantique pas la
mer sans marée stagnante et soupe au
moule qui lèche le sud un petit clapot
mièvre houle anglaise doré finissante
fait frémir ses varices
je vous parle de la mère venue d'ouest
qui claque aux sables vierge et vas y
viens monte et descend comme un amant
formidable la mer tour à tour miroir de
plomb mort aux furies galopante la mer
au pied de l'escalier de pierre ou la
plage n'en finit plus de s'étaler les
eaux sont basses et leurs rumeurs
feutrée comme une confidence ou juin un
peul écume unique frisson de bruit dans
cette splendeur inconcevable du
crépuscule de juin
alors les enfants saturé d'autoroute à
vide d'air marin casse la paix du soir
un coup de rire claquant il se vautre
sur le sable et les traînes y est si
courte à plat ventre avec des ferveurs
de pâtes embrassant la terre sainte
3 goélands choqué 100 volts infiniment
c'est un temps contre nature comme le
ciel bleu des peintures comme l'oubli
des tortures il fait beau comme jamais
un temps à rire et courir un temps à ne
pas mourir un temps à craindre le pire
il fait beau comme jamais
anne arrive doucement sur ses pieds du
bermuda montparnasse et tee shirt
diaphane elle pétille rassurante sous le
grand chapeau de paille tressée elle
pose sa main sur l'omoplate de l'homme
pour regarder la mer ensemble tu devrais
écrire un roman balnéaire
elle dit ça comme on dit du droit mais
d'une laine ou bien il faudrait dès le
faux nez à ta mère c'est sur ce ton
léger qui nous vient pour émettre des
insignifiances si peu fondamental que
l'instant d'après on ne sait plus très
bien si on les a dit à haute voix ou
simplement penser mais c'est aussi le
ton qu'on prend pour exprimer des
évidences si fortement à six qu'elle
n'appelle même pas de réponse toujours
est il qu'il a dit tu devrais écrire un
roman balnéaire
pour l'heure elle regarde intensément la
mer plissés de petits éclats blancs
il lui dit qu'elle est folle qu'on ne
fait pas des romans balnéaires comme on
fait les foins il faut l'idée vaut les
idées
l'échafaudage la plume sereine et lente
et peut-être le talent d'écrivain
elle reçoit le couchant de plein fouet
et france le museau pour conter sa
progéniture qui fait le dauphin débutant
à la frange de légumes
[Musique]
il dit vu d'ici on dirait des fourmis
déconnant sur un ourlet
elle rit voilà ça c'est un joli début
pour le livre les enfants jouaient dans
la mer à marée basse vue de la terrasse
on aurait dit des fourmis déconnant sur
un ourlet
oui d'accord mais après il faut une
histoire je sais pas moi
la mer est plate et rassurante mais le
vent souffle de terre est le plus petit
enfant dans sa boîte plastique disparaît
à jamais vers les amériques la douleur
des parents fait peine à voir
le malheur se lève et le soleil se
couchera ton t
elle mais non ce serait ce sera encore
de l'humour de cimetières ça va comme ça
tu as déjà donné trouve autre chose
je sais pas moi
les russes débarquent voix par
l'atlantique sont originales
le jour continue rouge de ne pas mourir
alexandre se dit qu'il est résolument
contre l'abolition du mois de juin
août et vulgaire août et vulgaire
transparent et moules méduses et les
banlieusards échoué si racornie sur le
sable dans un boa glapissant de congés
payés à lutiner
ou pulls à frites et les salles grâce en
août le pauvre en caleçon l'est mains
sur les hanches face à la mer l'oeil
vide et désemparé n'ose pas penser
qu'ils s'emmerdent intensément
de peur que l'omniprésence de sa femelle
indélébile de sa bouée canard grotesque
et de son chien approximatif ne lui
fasse douter de l'opportunité posthume
du front populaire
le mois de juin est autrement gracieux
en juin les jours sont longs et blonds
comme les débiles scandinave au sein
mouillée qui rit dans la vague jusqu'à
la mi nuit en juin au marché des
pêcheurs on ne s'inquiète pas encore on
flâne derrière le port la tomate cerise
est pour rien les chauffe-eau d'âge de
la maraîchine on la croque au sel sur le
sable avec une branche de basilic et un
verre de vin blanc de brême glace et
vivre la ville en août vivre la mer en
juin c'est l'ultime aristocratie et la
rare élégance de l'estivant hexagonal
ce soir ils ont sorti la grande table de
chaînes sur la terrasse face à l'océan
le mur blanc surchauffe et renvoie la
chaleur accumulée du jour pourpre élan
comme un prélat le soleil descend
religieusement sur l'horizon pénible
comme une ch'ti rouge avalés par la mer
et alexandre se demande combien de
phrases aussi bigrement politique il
faut caser dans un roman au balnéaire
pour que ce soit aussi beau qu'un
romande sous bois solognot avec des
senteurs de mousse et des écureuils
hystérique qui viennent manger dans la
main de maurice genevoix
t'as pas vu les filles de mandanne
pourquoi anne demande-t-elle tabac vu
les filles
les enfants rethel disparu si oui où qui
quand comment pourquoi qu'est ce que ça
peut [ __ ] vous le saurez en écoutant
demain à la même heure sur cette antenne
les aventures du mois de juin une
bouleversante saga en deux trois ou
douze épisodes ça dépend de toute façon
il me laisse faire ce que je veux à
france inter je peux même dire z et
mitterrand poil aux dents
alors qu'à radio varsovie on a tout
juste le droit de dire pinochet est un
co
quant à ces féroces cela je le dis c'est
pas pour capter ils font rien qu'à mûrir
dans nos campagnes
[Musique]
c'est le moment